e
saison. 70 ans et dans les 70
ans, on avait jamais connu une
année virtuelle en dernier. On
espère que celle qui commence
maintenant sera meilleure. Voici
mon reportage.
- C'est semaine de dévoilement
de programmation dans plusieurs
théâtres du pays.
À Montréal, le Théâtre du
Nouveau Monde a ouvert le bal.
ANNE-MARIE CADIEUX,
comédienne
- Je suis très fébrile, je suis
très heureuse, j'ai hâte
et le public nous le rend bien.
Je sens... Je sens que là,
de lancer une saison, mon dieu
c'est comme un miracle.
- Anne-Marie Cadieux sera
à l'affiche d'Embrasse,
une nouvelle pièce écrite
par Michel Marc Bouchard
durant la pandémie.
MICHEL MARC BOUCHARD,
dramaturge
- Je pense qu'on va avoir besoin
de s'embrasser, on va avoir
besoin d'un câlin après toute
cette épreuve.
- Le TNM espère pouvoir
présenter les spectacles devant
500 spectateurs dans une salle
qui peut en accueillir 800.
Et contrairement à la saison
dernière, pas question
de présenter des pièces moins
ambitieuses.
LORRAINE PINTAL, directrice
générale et artistique, TNM
- On n'a pas du tout imaginé
une saison avec moins d'acteurs,
moins de décors, mais au
contraire, on est
dans le foisonnement de notre
expression artiste
et je trouvais ça important
de le faire.
- Au Trident, à Québec,
le lancement aura lieu demain.
ANNE-MARIE BOUCHER-OLIVIER,
dir. art., théatre Le Trident
- On a tellement été
dans la crainte que là, on est
juste dans le bonheur de
retrouver la scène et les
spectateurs. C'est des grandes
distributions. On engage
70 acteurs cette année. Donc des
distribution à 20 à 12, des
grands spectacles et puis s'il y
a une quatrième vague, on
surfera dessus. Mais pour
l'instant, on a tellement été...
on a gagné beaucoup
de souplesse, disons,
dans la dernière année.
(rires)
- Et mercredi, ce sera au tour
de Duceppe de lancer
sa programmation. Ils ont choisi
de jouer de prudence. Après
Manuel de la vie Sauvage,
une grosse production présentée
à compter de septembre,
on se tournera vers de plus
petits spectacles à l'automne,
avant de revenir à des pièces
de plus grandes envergure
en 2022.
DAVID LAURIN, co-directeur
artistique, Duceppe
- On sentait la notion de risque
d'une éventuelle vague
et ... je me croise les doigts
en vous parlant... mais on se
disait qu'en janvier, idéalement
une très forte partie
de la population serait double
vaccinée et aurait envie de voir
des shows à grand déploiement.
- Après une dernière année
sombre pour les théâtres,
la lumière est de retour
sur scène.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M